good news this morning we continue our
kindness 101 series with Steve Hartman
sharing stories built around kindness
and character and the people who've
mastered those qualities and don't quit
on us yet because today's lesson is all
about grit Steve and his kids are going
to introduce us to someone who proves
you don't have to be the biggest guy on
the team to have the biggest impact as
long as you've got Grit
good morning I'm here with my daughter
Meryl and today's lesson is going to be
rough that's right because today's class
is about
grit for a definition let's go over to
your brother Emmett now at the
dictionary desk good morning Emmett good
morning gray is kind of like a
combination of perseverance and passion
it's to have an Unstoppable spirit for
the Long Haul good now Meryl in front of
you I have placed a picture of Einstein
and a block of wood will you please sand
the block of wood with the picture of
Einstein
how's it going it's not good okay now
try this piece of sandpaper
any better what
point is it doesn't matter how smart you
are you're not going to achieve your
goals if you don't have grit that little
bit of stubbornness to grind down
whatever blocks your way I have met a
lot of people who possess this attribute
but none more impressive than the person
you're about to meet it's a classic from
our archives about one of the most
important keys to success grit
[Music]
the Brandywine Bulldogs in Wilmington
Delaware have one of the most unlikely
football players in America today not
just because this guy is so little but
because this guy
is a girl
I knew that I wanted to play football
and I knew that I wanted to start on
varsity and nothing stood in the way
from it at four foot eight senior
Felicia Perez is one of the shortest
kids in her school and she's not a
kicker like many girls who play high
school ball no coach Isaiah Mays says
Felicia came to him with a different
position in mind a girl could
technically play anything but most of
them don't say they want to play
linebacker right away that's right
linebacker and you know it's a physical
position you get hit every play and
she's gotten rocked a couple times when
she gets right back up
Felicia says it's everything she ever
dreamed for as long as she can remember
she's wanted to play football but it
took a while to convince her parents
[Applause]
pushing for it was like Mom Dad really
want to play and they were like okay
well let's go sign you up they thought
you were bluffing that you really didn't
want to yeah they thought I was bluffing
so you called their Bluff I did I think
I still do
and it wasn't just her parents who were
skeptical when she went to sign up
Felicia was directed at first to the
cheerleading table
it was the beginning of a lot of false
assumptions
and some bullying came to weight
training and everybody started laughing
I was just like you shouldn't be playing
football then you know she hit me hard
and I was like all right well maybe she
should be playing football and that yeah
was the end of that that's not a girl
playing that's a that's a football
player they say no one dare laugh now
you got to protect yours she family to
us so that means standing up for Felicia
when the other team's Target her and by
all accounts they do Target her she's
had more than a handful of broken
fingers and they try to bruise her ego
too with insults
so why not just take the easy way out we
never take the easy way out play but you
would have avoided all that pain you're
right I would have but would I be here
today
no
nor would she be here Felicia Perez
joins us now hello Felicia
good morning Steve
what did you do after high school
I decided I was going to join the Marine
Corps for the next four years how'd you
pick the Marines I think I know the
answer but
I didn't want the easy way out I never
do that's called cheating yourself when
we never do that for those of us who
aren't as gritty as you do you have any
suggestions for ramping up our game
if you don't have it you have to find it
everyone has it it's just a matter of
are you gonna allow yourself to just do
the bare minimum
or are you going to allow yourself to do
what you you don't think you can do and
achieve the unbelievable
you do any motivational speaking
I do not now you do now you do
thank you so much I really appreciate
your words and your wisdom and your Grit
thank you
good lesson and proof you don't have to
be a smooth Einstein as long as you've
got Grit thanks for watching and don't
forget to stay kind
[Music]
my favorite part is Meryl at the end
don't forget but I love the story I love
this I love all the stories actually
yeah just a little great yes yeah
that'll go a long way yeah I think you
think about the Marine Corps even the
Marine Corps a little grittier you're
right about that grit never a bad thing
never a bad thing